Over the past three years, the COVID-19 pandemic has brought into sharp focus why it's so important to understand the psychology of group behavior. In many places, the course of the pandemic turned on how government leaders communicated with the public and whether people followed, ignored, or fought the advice of public health officials. The pandemic was a shock to most of us, but the behavioral questions it raised have long preoccupied psychologists. What makes people follow authority figures or reject them? How does group identity affect people's behavior? Today, we're going to talk about these questions and more broadly, the psychology of crowds and group behavior. When people think about group behavior,
在过去三年里，新冠疫情让我们深刻认识到，理解群体行为心理学为何如此重要。在许多地方，疫情的发展取决于政府领导人如何与公众沟通，以及民众是遵循、忽视还是抗拒公共卫生官员的建议。疫情对我们大多数人来说是一场冲击，但它所引发的关于行为的问题长期以来一直吸引着心理学家。是什么让人们听从权威人物或拒绝他们？群体认同如何影响人们的行为？今天，我们将探讨这些问题，更广泛地探讨人群和群体行为的心理学。当人们想到群体行为时，
the image that may come to mind is of mob mentality, the idea that people can get swept up in the madness of a crowd and lose their ability to reason and follow their own good judgment. But how accurate is that image? Do people behave differently in a group or a crowd compared with when they're on their own? If so, how? What are the roles of leaders and followers in groups? What can we learn from re-examining some of the classic psychology studies on obedience and authority,
脑海中浮现的可能是暴民心态的形象，即人们会被人群的疯狂所裹挟，失去理智和遵循自身良好判断的能力。但这种形象有多准确？人们在群体或人群中的行为与独自一人时有什么不同吗？如果是，如何不同？领导者和追随者在群体中扮演什么角色？通过重新审视一些关于服从和权威的经典心理学研究，我们能学到什么，
such as the Milgram Shock Experiments and the Stanford Prison Experiment? And what have we learned about collective behavior from the COVID-19 pandemic? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. My guest today is Dr. Stephen Reischer, a professor of psychology at the University of St. Andrews in Scotland. He is an expert in group psychology and collective behavior and has studied how people behave in crowds, the factors that influence whether or not people obey authority figures,
比如米尔格拉姆电击实验和斯坦福监狱实验？从新冠疫情中，我们对集体行为有了什么了解？欢迎收听《心理学对话》（Speaking of Psychology），这是美国心理学协会（American Psychological Association）的旗舰播客，旨在探讨心理学科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯（Kim Mills）。我今天的嘉宾是苏格兰圣安德鲁斯大学的心理学教授斯蒂芬·赖舍尔（Stephen Reicher）博士。他是群体心理学和集体行为专家，一直研究人们在人群中的行为、影响人们是否服从权威人物的因素，
and how groups can be a force for social change. He is a member of SAGE, a behavioral science advisory committee that has advised the UK government throughout the COVID-19 pandemic. He also writes regularly for the public in outlets, including The Guardian and the Conversation, about how behavioral science can inform our understanding of social issues such as pandemic behavior, crowd policing, authoritarianism, and more. Dr. Reischer is a fellow of the British Academy
以及群体如何成为社会变革的力量。他是SAGE（一个在整个新冠疫情期间为英国政府提供咨询的行为科学咨询委员会）的成员。他还定期为《卫报》和《对话》等公众媒体撰稿，内容关于行为科学如何增进我们对社会问题的理解，例如疫情期间的行为、人群警务、威权主义等。赖舍尔博士是英国国家学术院
and the Royal Society of Edinburgh. Dr. Reisch, thank you for joining me today. It's a real pleasure to talk to you. You've studied the psychology of group behavior for decades, and over the past three years, you've thought a lot about group behavior during a pandemic. So given your knowledge of collective behavior, were you surprised at all about how it turned out?
和爱丁堡皇家学会的院士。赖舍尔博士，非常感谢您今天能来。很高兴能与您交谈。几十年来，您一直在研究群体行为心理学，在过去的三年里，您对大流行期间的群体行为进行了很多思考。那么，鉴于您对集体行为的了解，您对最终的结果感到意外吗？
I mean, in some way, of course, the COVID pandemic was something unprecedented, that's something we've never lived through in our lifetime, so there were many surprises about the virus, about the way it evolved, about behaviour as well. I think two things that we learned, however, was, first of all, often when people think about psychology, they think of it as a matter of individuals' individual behaviour,
我的意思是，在某种程度上，新冠疫情当然是前所未有的，这是我们一生中从未经历过的事情，因此关于病毒、关于它的演变方式以及关于行为，都有很多意想不到的事情。然而，我认为我们学到了两点：首先，通常当人们想到心理学时，他们会认为这是关于个人行为的问题，
they think of it less when it comes to societal issues and policy issues and so on. And yet during COVID, it became quite clear that the behavioural dimension was absolutely critical, because certainly before we had a vaccine, the main way in which we could limit transmission of the virus was by keeping people physically apart. Now, that's very difficult because we're social beings, and we learnt how much we lose when we're apart. So the great dilemma of how could you keep people socially together while physically apart. I think that was a huge challenge and raised huge issues. The second point was that there is a sense that when people behave in groups, in crowds, under stress, they tend not to be at their best, to put it very mildly.
当涉及到社会问题和政策问题等时，他们较少从心理学角度去考虑。然而在新冠疫情期间，人们变得非常清楚，行为维度绝对至关重要，因为在拥有疫苗之前，我们限制病毒传播的主要方法就是让人们保持物理距离。现在，这非常困难，因为我们是社会性动物，我们了解到彼此分离时我们失去了多少。因此，如何在保持物理距离的同时在社会层面将人们联系在一起，这是一个巨大的困惑。我认为这是一个巨大的挑战，并引发了许多重大的问题。第二点是，人们有一种感觉，当人们在压力下在群体、人群中表现时，说得委婉一点，他们往往表现不出最好的一面。
And so you already mentioned the notion of mobs, that crowds are irrational and destructive. And when it comes to emergencies, we have this image of panic. You can't have a good Hollywood disaster film without people running for the exits and waving their hands in the air and blocking up the exits and making things even worse. Now, the interesting thing is that over the last three decades or so, research on behaviour and emergencies actually shows a very different picture, that when you do get emergencies, when you do get disasters, actually people come together.
因此你已经提到了暴民的概念，即人群是不理智且具有破坏性的。当谈到紧急情况时，我们对恐慌有这种印象。如果没有人奔向出口、挥舞双手、堵塞出口并把事情变得更糟的好莱坞灾难片，那就不是一部好的灾难片。现在有趣的是，在过去三十年左右的时间里，关于紧急情况下行为的研究实际上显示了一幅非常不同的画面，即当你真正遇到紧急情况、遇到灾难时，人们实际上会团结在一起。
People develop a sense of shared identity. We're in this together. And so they support each other and they help each other. And if people die, often it's not because they trample over each other in the scramble for the exits. It's because they help each other and don't leave as quickly as they can. You saw that in 9-11. I mean, as the firemen and firewomen rushed into the Twin Towers, an act of incredible bravery, they discovered that actually people were self-organizing,
人们会产生一种共同的认同感。我们同舟共济。因此他们互相支持，互相帮助。如果有人死亡，通常不是因为他们在争夺出口时践踏彼此。而是因为他们互相帮助，没有以最快的速度离开。你在“9·11”事件中看到了这一点。我的意思是，当消防员冲进双子塔时，那是一种令人难以置信的勇敢行为，他们发现实际上人们在进行自我组织，
and in many ways were organizing themselves and didn't need the fire officers to help them. And that's not unique. We found the same in the UK. when there were bombs in London and in 2005. So as I say, the literature challenges this notion of panic, shows that by and large people come together and support each other and that resilience is not a quality that resides in particular individual. It's a quality that comes about between people
在很多方面他们都在自我组织，不需要消防员来帮助他们。这并非个例。我们在英国也发现了同样的情况，2005年伦敦发生爆炸案时也是如此。正如我所说，相关文献对这种恐慌的概念提出了挑战，表明大体上人们会团结起来并互相支持，而且韧性并不是存在于某个特定个体身上的品质。它是一种产生于人与人之间的品质，
when they start thinking in terms of we rather than in terms of I. And albeit, now it is grace, the governor of New York, New York, Andrew Cuomo put it very well at the beginning when he said, look, this is a we thing. It's not an I thing. Get your head around the we concept. Well, that's what I've been trying to do for the last 40 years or so. Get my head around the we concept. That's what I learned from COVID. And that's what I think what I'd learned before COVID helped me in terms of trying to understand what was going on. How does anonymity affect people's behavior in a crowd? I think that's a really interesting question because it's often the question that people ask. It's often the question that was asked in classic crowd psychology.
当他们开始用“我们”而不是“我”来思考时。尽管如此，正如纽约州州长安德鲁·科莫（Andrew Cuomo）在开始时很好地表达的那样，他说，听着，这是一件关于“我们”的事。这不是一件关于“我”的事。搞清楚“我们”这个概念。嗯，这就是我过去40年左右一直在尝试做的事。搞清楚“我们”这个概念。这就是我从新冠疫情中学到的。这就是我在新冠疫情前学到的知识，它在帮助我理解正在发生的事情方面对我有所帮助。匿名性如何影响人群中人们的行为？我认为这是一个非常有趣的问题，因为人们经常会问这个问题。这也是经典人群心理学中经常被问到的问题。
So the most famous of all crowd psychologists, a Frenchman with a name Gustave LeBourne, who wrote a book in 1895 called The Crowd, which has been described as the most influential psychology text of a Frenchman. all time that not only describes it helped form the mass politics of the 20th and 21st centuries. He started his analysis from the assumption that people are anonymous in crowds, that they lose their sense of self, they lose their standards, and they become incapable of thinking. They become like sheet led by others. And also they revert to a more primitive self and behave destructively. And this notion, what LeBorg called submergence, was translated into modern social
因此，所有人群心理学家中最著名的是一个名叫古斯塔夫·勒庞（Gustave Le Bon）的法国人，他在1895年写了一本名为《乌合之众》（The Crowd）的书，该书被描述为有史以来最有影响力的法国心理学著作，它不仅进行了描述，还帮助塑造了20和21世纪的大众政治。他的分析始于这样一个假设：人们在人群中是匿名的，他们失去了自我意识，失去了标准，变得丧失思考能力。他们变得像被他人引领的绵羊一样。而且他们还会退回到更原始的自我，表现出破坏性行为。勒庞所说的这种“没入”概念，在现代社会中被转化成了
psychology through the notion of de-individuation, which asked the question, what happens when people are anonymous in groups? And many studies were done, which took people, which made them anonymous, which looked at their behaviours, and generally came to the conclusion that people behave more negatively when nobody is watching them. Now, there are a number of problems, but the most fundamental problem is this? It's the wrong question. Because when you look closely at crowds, people are not anonymous in crowds. Most people go to crowds, into crowds with people they know. There's an old study by some called Aveni, which shows that 77% of people in crowds go with friends, with acquaintances, with people they know from similar organizations. That many crowds,
通过“去个性化”概念引入心理学，该概念提出了这样一个问题：当人们在群体中匿名时会发生什么？人们进行了许多研究，将人群置于匿名状态，观察他们的行为，并普遍得出结论：当没有人看着他们时，人们表现得更具负面性。现在，这里存在许多问题，但最根本的问题是这个：这是错误的问题。因为当你仔细观察人群时，人群中的人并不是匿名的。大多数人去人群中时，身边都有他们认识的人。阿维尼（Aveni）等人的一项老研究表明，人群中77%的人是与朋友、熟人、从相似组织中认识的人一起去的。许多人群，
especially many of the riots, which most concern people, were those of communities. And so, what this question revealed was less what crowds do than the fact that those studying them were outsiders who had an outside perspective. To them, people were anonymous, even if they weren't anonymous to each other. And that outside perspective, that lack of actually looking at what crowds were like led to a whole series of fantasies and errors about the crowd. Early crowd psychology, in a sense was a science based on the fantasies of outside observers who looked on crowds with fear because they thought the crowds would challenge the status quo, would challenge their dominance. So as I say, it's an excellent question, not so much because it reveals something about crowds,
特别是那些最令人担忧的骚乱，往往是社区的骚乱。因此，这个问题所揭示的与其说是人群的行为，不如说是那些研究人群的人是具有外部视角的局外人。对他们来说，人们是匿名的，即使对彼此来说并非如此。这种外部视角，缺乏对人群真实面貌的实际观察，导致了一系列关于人群的幻想和错误。从某种意义上说，早期的人群心理学是一门基于外部观察者幻想的科学，他们带着恐惧看待人群，因为他们认为人群会挑战现状，会挑战他们的统治地位。所以正如我所说，这是一个极好的问题，与其说它揭示了关于人群的一些东西，
but it reveals something about the fundamental problem of crowd psychology, classically, which it was based on the perceptions of the outsider rather than the realities of what goes on in the crowd. So in some sense, then people are maybe clumping together with people who are like-minded. I mean, I'm thinking of, for example, what happened at the January 6th riot on Capitol Hill here in the United States. I mean, those people came together. Many of them knew each other, even though they were anonymous to us.
不如说它揭示了经典人群心理学的一个根本问题，即它建立在局外人的看法之上，而不是建立在人群中实际发生的事情的现实之上。所以在某种意义上，人们可能会和志同道合的人聚在一起。我的意思是，我想到了例如美国国会山1月6日骚乱中发生的事情。我的意思是，那些人聚在了一起。他们中的许多人互相认识，尽管对我们来说他们是匿名的。
Some of them are not anonymous anymore. Or even just this past weekend where we saw the coronation of King Charles III, where people were organizing into people who are in favor of the monarchy and then the people who are yelling not my king. So is this what you're talking about? Well, I spent my weekend seven hours on Saturday in the rain standing in those crowds, looking at those crowds. There are many joys of crowds, but standing in London drizzle for seven hours is not part of it, I have to say. If we go back to what I was saying about LeBourne and the classic assumption, that what goes on in crowds is that people lose their identities,
他们中的一些人不再匿名了。或者甚至是就在上个周末，我们看到了查尔斯三世国王的加冕典礼，人们分为支持君主制的人和高喊“这不是我的国王”的人。所以这就是你在谈论的吗？嗯，我上周末在雨中在那些人群中站了七个小时，观察着那些人群。人群有许多乐趣，但我必须说，在伦敦的毛毛雨中站七个小时并不在其中。如果我们回到我刚才关于勒庞和经典假设的说法，即人群中发生的事情是人们失去了身份认同，
therefore lose their standards, lose control. It rooted in a particular sense of the self, that really core concept in psychology. Often in psychology, we think about the self, we think about what makes me unique, what makes me different from you. And yet, if I was to ask any of your audience, if I was to ask you, who are you,
从而失去了标准，失去了控制。它植根于对自我的特定理解，即心理学中的那个真正核心概念。通常在心理学中，当我们思考自我时，我们会思考是什么让我独一无二，是什么让我与你不同。然而，如果我要问你的任何听众，如果我要问你，你是谁，
you would tell me certain things about yourself. friendly, I like cats, I've got grey hair, I've got no hair, whatever it would be. But you'd also tell me things about the group memberships to which you belong. You tell me you're a woman. You might tell me you're American. You might tell me, I'm a Catholic, you might tell me a whole series of group memberships. So our identity is actually much more complex. We have individual, personal identities, which are about me and how I differ from you. We have group or social identity. which are about the groups to which I belong and how we differ from they. So the core argument of contemporary crowd psychology is to say, look,
你会告诉我关于你自己的某些事情。友好，我喜欢猫，我有白头发，我没有头发，无论是什么。但你也会告诉我关于你所属的群体成员身份的事情。你告诉我你是一个女人。你可能会告诉我你是美国人。你可能会告诉我，我是一个天主教徒，你可能会告诉我一系列的群体成员身份。所以我们的身份其实要复杂得多。我们有个人身份，关乎我和我与你的不同。我们有群体或社会身份，关乎我所属的群体以及我们与他们的不同。因此，当代人群心理学核心论点是：
LeBor had a limited view of the self to just the individual self. And his assumption was that if you lose the individual self, there's nothing left. What seems to be going on, rather, is what happens in crowds is that people shift from the personal self to the social self or social identity, from I to we. And they start acting in terms of the norms and the values of the group. So it's not that you lose identity and lose control, you shift control to the norms and values of the group. Now, certainly some groups have got appalling, pernicious values. You know, Nazi crowds, you know, genocidal, anti-Semitic, authoritarian and so on.
勒庞对自我的看法仅限于个人自我，视野十分有限。他的假设是，如果你失去了个人自我，那就一无所有了。相反，似乎正在发生的是，在人群中发生的事情是人们从个人自我转变为社会自我或社会认同，从“我”转变为“我们”。他们开始根据群体的规范和价值观行事。所以并不是说你失去了身份认同和失去了控制，而是你将控制权转移到了群体的规范和价值观上。当然，有些群体的价值观极其糟糕、恶劣。你知道，纳粹人群，你知道的，种族灭绝的、反犹太主义的、威权主义的等等。
But they weren't mindless. They weren't senseless. And the pathology was not a psychopathology, a loss of mind. It was much more a socio-pathology. It was rooted in those values. So, in a sense, you know, to invoke Dickens, crowds are sometimes the best of worlds and sometimes are the worst of worlds. They act and they tell us about the values of a particular group.
但他们并不是毫无理智的。他们并不是毫无意义的。这种病理学不是精神病理学，即失去理智。它更像是一种社会病理学。它植根于那些价值观中。所以，从某种意义上说，（借用狄更斯的话）人群有时是最好的世界，有时是最坏的世界。他们的行为向我们展示了一个特定群体的价值观。
They tell us about who they see as their friends and who they see as their foes. And I remember reading a wonderful historical study. It was about crowd events that had happened in France over a hundred-year period. And they seemed bizarre. People couldn't understand them until you looked at the viewpoint of the labourers themselves. And the author, he says, the targets of crowds, glitter in the eye of history as a measure of the labourers conception of society. So crowds always tell you something, and I think the crowds that assaulted the capital
他们告诉我们他们认为谁是朋友，谁是敌人。我记得读过一篇精彩的历史研究。那是关于在法国一个世纪里发生的人群事件。它们看起来很诡异。人们无法理解它们，直到你从劳动者自身的角度来看待这个问题。作者说，人群的目标在历史的目光中闪烁，成为劳动者对社会观念的一种衡量。所以人群总是能告诉你一些事情，我认为冲击国会山的人群
told you very clearly about a particular ideology and who they saw as their enemies and who they saw as their friends, and their targets were likewise differentiated in the officers they went into the things they desecrated and the things they left alone. So, sometimes bad, sometimes destructive, but not mindless and not mad. So what do these insights into crowd behavior tell us about how we could better police crowds? So one of the problems is that this classical view of crowds, this view of crowds as inherently dangerous, inherently mindless, inherently destructive, often leads to policing strategies that are indiscriminate and which assume that even if the people involved in crowds are okay,
非常清楚地向你展示了一种特定的意识形态，以及他们认为谁是他们的敌人，谁是他们的朋友，他们的目标同样体现在他们进入的官员办公室、他们亵渎的东西以及他们置之不理的东西上。所以，有时糟糕，有时具有破坏性，但并非毫无理智，也并非疯狂。那么，对人群行为的这些深刻理解告诉我们，我们该如何更好地对人群进行警务管理呢？所以问题之一是，这种对人群的经典看法，这种将人群视为本质上危险的、本质上无理智的、本质上具有破坏性的看法，往往会导致不加区分的警务策略，这些策略认为，即使参与人群的人是好的，
once they're in crowds, they're dangerous, which leads to a generalized repression of crowds. You use tactics, which, for instance, treat all crowd members the same, which sweep the street and knock aside anybody, whoever they are. Now, the danger with that is that, I've already spoken about how we should think of crowds as groups. But often in a physical crowd, in a single physical crowd, you can have multiple psychological crowds or none at all. So, for instance, if you have a physical crowd of people in the shopping street, they're not necessarily a psychological crowd. They don't have a sense of we. Or if you go to a football game.
一旦人群聚集，他们就是危险的，这导致了对人群的普遍压制。你使用的战术，比如说，把所有人群成员一视同仁，清扫街道，把任何人撞开，不管他们是谁。现在，这样做的危险在于，我之前已经谈过我们应该如何把人群视为群体。但通常在一个物理人群中，在一个单独的物理人群中，你可能会有多个心理人群，或者根本没有。所以，举个例子，如果你在购物街上有一群人，他们不一定是一个心理人群。他们没有我们这种意识。或者如果你去看一场足球比赛。
When I say football, I mean soccer. Soccer, and you mean something else. But still, in the same crowd, it's the same physical crowd, but you've got different groups, supporters of one side, the other side, neutrals, and so on. And often in political crowds, you get a whole series of different groups with different values, different aims, different intentions. Some might be to be disrupted, to be violent, to be dangerous. On the whole, most aren't. Now, the danger is that if you treat everybody's the same. If the police assume that everyone is dangerous and treat everybody as dangerous, the danger
当我说足球时，我指的是英式足球。足球，而你指的是别的。但是，在同一个人群中，它是同一个物理人群，但你有不同的群体，一边的支持者，另一边的支持者，中立者，等等。通常在政治人群中，你会发现一连串不同的群体，有着不同的价值观念、不同的目标、不同的意图。有些可能是去破坏，去施暴，去制造危险。总的来说，大多数人不是这样的。现在，危险在于，如果你把所有人都一视同仁。如果警方假设每个人都是危险的，并把每个人都当作危险人物对待，危险
is they can change the nature of the group composition and get the majority to side with a violent minority in saying, well, look, the police are our enemy. The police are against us, you see. And so we have developed forms of policing, which are about starting from the premise, not crowds are bad, let's stop them. But let's see what the crowd is trying to do. Let's see what we can facilitate. Let's get the crowd on our side against those who want to be violent. And when you have facilitative policing, often you find that, number one, that the majority of crowds are on your side. and secondly, they self-police in ways that mean the police don't have to intervene.
在于他们会改变群体构成的性质，让多数人站在暴力少数派的一边，说，看吧，警察是我们的敌人。你看，警察在反对我们。因此，我们发展出了这样的警务形式：其前提不是人群是坏的，让我们阻止他们。而是看看人群正试图做什么。看看我们能促成什么。让我们把人群争取到我们这边，反对那些想要施暴的人。当你有了促成性的警务时，你通常会发现，第一，多数人群是站在你这边的；第二，他们会以某种方式进行自我管理，这意味着警察无需介入。
And as police officers themselves will tell you, often the most effective forms of policing are where the police themselves don't have to intervene, where they facilitate crowd self-policing. Let me give you a concrete example of this. From long ago, I think it was in 1987. I'd been studying crowds for more years than I'd like to remember. And it was in the midst of the rise of the anti-apartheid movement, the anti-apartheid campaign.
正如警官们自己会告诉你的那样，通常最有效的警务形式是警察自己不必介入，他们促成人群的自我管理。让我给你一个这方面的具体例子。很久以前，我想是在1987年。我研究人群的年头比我愿意承认的还要多。那正值反种族隔离运动、反种族隔离运动兴起的高峰期。
And there was a demonstration in the midst of London. And people had thought there would be about 10,000 people there. In the end, about 100,000 people turned up going to Trafalgar Square. Now, if you know London, you know that there's a problem there because of South African embassy is on Trafalgar Square. And there was beginning to be trouble. People were pressing up against the South African embassy. It was a symbol of the enemy.
伦敦市中心有一场游行。人们原以为那里会有大约一万人。最后，大约十万人涌向了特拉法加广场。现在，如果你了解伦敦，你就知道那里有个问题，因为南非大使馆就在特拉法加广场上。当时已经开始出现麻烦了。人们正朝着南非大使馆挤去。那是敌人的象征。
There were beginning to be a few bricks thrown. They could have been a major riot. But there wasn't. And the reason why there wasn't was because Jesse Jackson at the time was the speaker. And as you know, Jesse Jackson was a charismatic, amazing speaker. And he united people by saying, look, he said, if there is a riot to then tomorrow you won't hear what's wrong with apartheid, tomorrow you'll hear what's wrong with anti-apartheid protesters. That's to the good of the South African regime. You'll be helping
当时已经开始有人扔砖头了。本可能演变成一场重大骚乱。但并没有。之所以没有发生，是因为杰西·杰克逊当时是演讲者。如你所知，杰西·杰克逊是一位极具个人魅力、令人惊叹的演讲者。他把人们团结起来，说道：听着，他说，如果发生骚乱，那么明天你们听不到种族隔离的错误在哪，明天你们听到的是反种族隔离抗议者的错误在哪。这对南非政权有利。你们是在帮助
the enemy, he said. And he said, chant with me free Nelson Mandela. And everybody linked arms, chant of free Nelson Mandela and those who were trying to be violent were completely isolated. So most people in the crowd don't want violence. And they know violence is going to be against them. And if you facilitate and work with them, you can use the crowd itself in order to avoid those forms of conflict. So we've been working for many years, in particular my colleague Clifford Stott, who is now doing a lot of work in the US with the police to try and spread these ideas of don't see a crowd as a problem. Don't see the crowd as inherently violent. Not only is that wrong, it's dangerous. It's a self-built.
敌人，他说。他说，跟我一起喊：释放纳尔逊·曼德拉。每个人都挽起手臂，高喊释放纳尔逊·曼德拉，那些企图施暴的人被彻底孤立了。所以人群中的大多数人并不想要暴力。他们知道暴力对他们不利。如果你去促成并与他们合作，你就可以利用人群本身来避免这些形式的冲突。因此，多年来我们一直在合作，尤其是我的同事克利福德·斯托特，他现在正在美国与警方开展大量工作，试图传播这些理念：不要把人群视为问题。不要认为人群天生具有暴力性。这不仅是错误的，而且是危险的。这是一个自我实现的
full in prophecy. What about for people who are in crowds, whether they have gone to a sporting event or they're going to a demonstration, are there things that they need to understand about crowd behavior that might make them safer in the event that something goes amok? Okay. So I've spoken to some extent so far about what you might call the cognitive shifts that happen in the crowd. That when you get into a crowd, what happens is you start thinking in terms of the norms and the values of the group, not your individual norms and values, but what characterizes our collective police. And also, in crowds, what matters is the good of the group. So you evaluate things in terms of the group norms and values. But those aren't the only shifts that happen in
预言。对于身处人群中的人来说，无论是去参加体育赛事还是去参加游行，是否有关于人群行为的事情是他们需要了解的，从而在发生混乱时能让他们更安全？好的。因此，到目前为止，我在某种程度上谈到了你所谓的在人群中发生的认知转变。当你进入人群时，发生的情况是，你开始按照群体的规范和价值观来思考，而不是你的个人规范和价值观，而是代表我们集体警惕的东西。此外，在人群中，重要的是群体的利益。所以你根据群体的规范和价值观来评估事物。但这些并不是发生的仅有的转变
a crowd. There is also a shift in social relations. And we've seen this in all sorts of fascinating ways. So when you're in a crowd and when people see each other as part of a shared identity, then people cease being other. They cease being, if you like, an impediment, a barrier to what you want to do. They become part of your extended self. They're part of us. They're with you. help you achieve what you want to achieve. And so you see all sorts of shifts towards intimacy. First of all, people trust each other more, people help each other more, people share things. They share sandwiches.
在人群中。社会关系也发生了转变。我们在各种迷人的方面都看到了这一点。因此，当你在人群中，当人们将彼此视为共享认同的一部分时，人们就不再是异类。如果你愿意的话，他们不再是你想要做的事情的阻碍、障碍。他们成为了你延伸自我的一部分。他们是我们的一部分。他们和你在一起，帮助你实现你想实现的目标。因此，你会看到各种向亲密关系转变的现象。首先，人们更加信任彼此，人们更多地帮助彼此，人们分享东西。他们分享三明治。
They share goods in ways that they would otherwise do so. They even, years ago we did a study, very simple study. It was a group rather than a crowd setting, but the logic is the same. We got people to smell sweaty t-shirts, disgusting sweaty t-shirts. My son said to me, is that what you do for a job, Dad? And I had to admit it was. And on the t-shirt is emblazoned the symbol of either your university or a rival university. And when it's the rival university, you find it disgusting.
他们以平时不会采取的方式分享物品。他们甚至在几年前做过一项研究，一项非常简单的研究。那是一个群体而不是人群的环境，但逻辑是一样的。我们让人们闻散发汗味的T恤，令人作呕的散发汗味的T恤。我儿子对我说，爸爸，这就是你的工作吗？我不得不承认是的。T恤上印有你所在大学或竞争对手大学的标志。当它是竞争对手的大学时，你会觉得它令人作呕。
Your face puckers in disgust. You do it for as short a time as you can. You rush over. We timed all these things. You rush over. You wash your hands with lots of soap for itself. When it's the in-group, T-shirt. I won't exactly say you like it, but you're much more casual about it. You kind of
你的脸因厌恶而皱起。你尽可能缩短闻的时间。你冲过去。我们对所有这些事情都进行了计时。你冲过去，用大量的肥皂洗手。当它是内群体的T恤时。我不会确切地说你喜欢它，但你对它要随意得多。你有点像
sniff it for a bit, stroll over, take it. Now, the important thing there is that if you think about it, disgust is the social ordering emotion. I can be in a room with you if I hate you. I can't be in a room with you if you disgust me. And so, again, the loss of disgust is one of many dimensions which allows people to come together to feel intimate, to feel friends. We did, well, there's an old anecdote that I would like, and we turned it into another experiment. The anecdote came from British politician, and he was talking about trains breaking down,
闻一会儿，走过去，拿走。现在，这里重要的事情是，如果你仔细想想，厌恶是一种维护社会秩序的情绪。如果我恨你，我可以和一个房间里的你共处。如果我对你感到恶心，我就无法和一个房间里的你共处。因此，再次强调，厌恶感的消失是众多维度之一，它使人们能够走到一起，感到亲密，感到像朋友。我们做过——好吧，有一个我喜欢的旧轶事，我们把它变成了另一个实验。这个轶事来自一位英国政治家，他当时在谈论火车抛锚的事情，
something that happens very often in the UK, I'm afraid. I know it also actually recently happens in Germany as well, so that ruined my stereotypes of Germany. But nonetheless, okay. Now, when you get on a train often, you are in a physical crowd. You are crowded up against people, you're pressed against them. But you try and keep yourself psychologically separate. If you're reading your newspaper, you try not to look over somebody else's shoulder
恐怕这在英国经常发生。我知道实际上最近在德国也发生了，这打破了我对德国的刻板印象。不过，没关系。现在，当你上车时，你通常处在一个物理人群中。你和人们挤在一起，你被挤在他们中间。但你试图在心理上保持独立。如果你在读报纸，你尽量不去看别人的肩膀
and you're annoyed if somebody looks after over your shoulder. You try to retain your personal space. But then the train breaks down and gradually you turn from an individual, traveler into a commuter, part of a group up against the train company, which is inefficient. And you start seeing that you've got something in common. And people start talking to each other and they even share their sandwiches. And I'm talking about British people here. So this is pretty radical stuff I'm talking about.
如果有人往你的肩膀后面看，你会感到恼火。你试图保留你的个人空间。但随后火车抛锚了，渐渐地，你从一个个人、旅客变成了一个通勤者，成为对抗效率低下的铁路公司群体的一部分。你开始发现你们有共同点。人们开始互相交谈，甚至分享他们的三明治。我这里说的是英国人。所以我说的可是相当激进的事情。
And we showed that happens in an experiment. Now, the point I'm trying to make is that therefore in crowds, not only do you have the same perspective on the world, you join together, you support each other, you co-act. And that makes crowds powerful. Because you've got a set of people working together to achieve the same thing. And often that allows you to do things you can't do in everyday life. Now, sometimes that's oppositional.
我们在一个实验中证明了这一点。现在，我要表达的观点是，因此在人群中，你不仅对世界有相同的看法，你们团结在一起，互相支持，共同行动。这使得人群变得强大。因为你们有一群人齐心协力去实现同一目标。通常这能让你做你在日常生活中做不到的事情。现在，有时这是对抗性的。
Sometimes you can challenge the police if you feel that the police stop you doing what you want to do. You're empowered. We also did work in a Hindu pilgrimage. Grimmage, the biggest crowd event in the world. It's an event that happens at the confluence of the Ganges and the Yamuna rivers in Alabad in in North India. It's on a 12-year cycle. Every year, about 5 million people go. Every sixth year, the half-mela, 20 million people go. The full meller, the cum meller, every 12 years, a hundred million people go in the month. And on a single day, I remember being there and 20 million people are around you. You know, the full mellor, the
有时，如果你觉得警察阻止你做你想做的事，你可以挑战警察。你被赋予了力量。我们还在一个印度教朝圣活动中做过工作。朝圣，世界上最大的人群活动。这是一个在恒河与亚穆纳河交汇处举行的活动，地点在北印度的阿拉哈巴德。这是一个12年的周期。每年大约有500万人去。每六年，即半大壶节，有2000万人去。完整的大壶节，大壶节，每12年有1亿人在一个月内前往。而在某一天，我记得我在那里，周围有2000万人。你知道，完整的大壶节，
The numbers are quite amazing. Now, the fascinating thing about the mellow is because it's that people experience this vast number of people, which is incredibly noisy and incredibly dirty, incredibly insanitory, as blissful. And they see it as blissful because they come together and people respect each other and give each other space to carry out their religious devotions, which is why they're there. So that sense of empowerment of agency, of I can do what I believe in, to me is at the core of the joy of crowds. And the irony is this.
这些数字相当惊人。现在，关于大壶节最迷人的事情是，因为人们体验到这庞大的人群，它极其嘈杂，极其肮脏，极其不卫生，但他们却感到极乐。他们认为这是极乐，因为他们聚到了一起，人们互相尊重，为彼此开展宗教灵修留出空间，这也是他们来那里的原因。因此，这种赋权的意识、自主性的意识、我能做我信仰之事的意识，在我看来是人群快乐的核心。而讽刺的是这一点。
People often attack crowds because they say are in crowds, you lose yourself in the collective. You lose agency. You become a sheep. The reason why people enjoy and are so joyous in crowds is because of precisely the opposite. And again, let me use a quotation I particularly. like, and again it's from a different setting, and it's from a French historian called Georges Lefevre, who was writing about revolutionary crowds in the French Revolution of 1789. And he said, perhaps it is only in the crowd that we lose our petty day-to-day concerns
人们经常攻击人群，因为他们说在人群中，你会在集体中迷失自我。你失去了自主权。你变成了一群绵羊。人们在人群中感到快乐并且如此欢乐的原因恰恰相反。同样，让我引用一句我特别喜欢的话，这也是在不同的背景下说的，它出自一位名叫乔治·勒费弗尔的法国历史学家，他描写的是1789年法国大革命中的革命人群。他说，也许只有在人群中，我们才会抛开琐碎的日常烦恼
and we become the subjects of history. We make history. And whether the history is your team winning the Super Bowl, or whether or whether the history is you transforming the politics of your society or whether the history is you being able to live a pure religious life that you believe in it, that's utterly exhilarating. So the emotion of crowds, the joy of crowds, doesn't show you that people are irrational. The joy of crowds is about people being able to turn their ideas into realities because they're empowered. And That, for me, makes crowds really fascinating things. Well, when you were observing this religious event in India and there were so many people there,
我们成为历史的主体。我们创造历史。无论这段历史是你们的球队赢得超级碗，还是这段历史是你改变了你所在社会的政治，或者这段历史是你能够过上你所信仰的纯粹的宗教生活，那都是无比振奋人心的。因此，人群的情绪，人群的快乐，并不表明人们是不理性的。人群的快乐在于，人们由于被赋予了力量，能够将他们的想法变为现实。对我而言，这使得人群成为非常迷人的事物。好吧，当你在印度观察这个宗教活动时，有那么多人在那里，
you weren't sharing in the religious experience, right? You were there as a psychologist studying them. Were you alone and how would that make you feel in a situation like that? Did you bring colleagues? I mean, I could see. I have been in, I'm originally from New York. I have been in some seriously scary crowds covering the redact. dedication of the Statue of Liberty many years ago. And I can tell you, I got stuck in a crowd in
你并没有分享这种宗教体验，对吧？你是作为一个研究他们的心理学家去的。你当时是一个人吗？在那种情况下，这会让你有什么感觉？你带了同事吗？我的意思是，我能理解。我曾经在——我原籍纽约。我经历过一些非常吓人的、负责报道自由女神像落成典礼多年后的人群。我可以告诉你，我曾陷入过
lower Manhattan, and we were panicked because you had no control over where you were going. You had to go where the sea of humanity took you. And it's kind of terrifying. How can you deal with that as a psychologist and even just as an individual citizen? Well, I think, I mean, when you look at accounts of danger in crowds, it is often when you are physically part of. of a crowd, you're not psychologically part of. So I've been part of, you know, several, say, football grounds. And I remember, you know, in the old days when a goal was scored, the crowd was searching, you physically be picked up and moved and put down somewhere else. And I remember that was that, that was a buzz. I mean, that was incredibly exciting.
曼哈顿下城，我们当时惊慌失措，因为你无法控制你要去哪里。你只能跟着人潮去到人潮带你去的地方。这有点可怕。作为一名心理学家，甚至仅仅作为一个普通公民，你该如何应对这种情况？嗯，我认为，我的意思是，当你查看有关人群危险的叙述时，通常是你从物理上成为了人群的一部分，而你在心理上并不是。所以我曾经是，你知道，几个，比如说，足球场的群体的一部分。我记得，你知道，在过去进球的时候，人群在涌动，你身体上会被抱起、移动并放到别的地方去。我记得那是——那是一种兴奋。我的意思是，那令人难以置信地兴奋。
However, you know, when I walk down the street and there's a crowd there, I turn into a grumpy old man, I mutter and I hate it and I find it profoundly negative. So I think it's quite interesting how our experience of crowds is profoundly different as a function of whether we feel psychologically part of them or not. Now, sometimes, however, the paradox is this, that if you are part of a crowd, let me step back. We'll mention a couple of other studies we've done. So one of the simplest studies I ever did was we,
然而，你知道，当我走在街上，那里有一群人时，我变成了一个脾气暴躁的老头，我嘟囔着，我很讨厌它，我发现这具有深刻的负面影响。所以我认为这非常有趣，我们对人群的体验有着深刻的不同，这取决于我们在心理上是否觉得是他们的一部分。然而，有时，矛盾在于，如果你是人群的一部分，让我退一步。我们将提及我们做过的其他几项研究。因此，我做过的最简单的研究之一是，我们
got people, and we said to them, look, please arrange the chairs. You're going to be talking to somebody. Arrange the chairs so you'll feel comfortable. Okay. And the person they were going to talk to was either in-group or out-group. We told them either it would be somebody from the same group as you or somebody. And they organise the chairs about 20 or 30% closer when it's in-group than out-group. And during COVID, because the issue of physical proximity was a big issue there,
让人们，我们对他们说，听着，请安排好椅子。你要和某人交谈。安排好椅子，让你觉得舒服。好的。他们要交谈的人要么是内群体，要么是外群体。我们告诉他们，那要么是和你来自同一群体的人，要么是其他人。当面对内群体而不是外群体时，他们把椅子排得比平时近了大约20%或30%。在疫情期间，由于物理距离的问题是一个大问题，
we did similar studies and we showed that people don't physically distance as much within group members. So there is an illusion of safety in groups. Now, a colleague of mine, John Drury, did some fantastic studies in the Hajj, which is the pilgrimage to Mecca, again, one of the biggest collective events in history. And one where, tragically, there have been a number of crutches people have been killed. Now, what we found was that the more that people identify as pilgrims, as Hajis, then the more connected they find to others, the more they seek out the center of the crowd. You want to be at the center of the crowd, just as if you're into a band, you don't want to be at the edge of the crowd.
我们做了类似的研究，结果表明，在内群体成员内部，人们不会保持那么远的物理距离。因此，群体中存在一种安全的错觉。现在，我的同事约翰·德鲁伊在朝觐（去麦加的朝圣之旅）中做了一些非常棒的研究，这也是历史上最大的集体活动之一。在这个活动中，悲惨的是，曾发生过许多踩踏事件，导致人员伤亡。现在，我们发现的是，人们对朝圣者（哈吉）的认同感越强，他们就会发现自己与他人的联系越紧密，他们就越会寻求人群的中心。你想成为人群的中心，就像如果你喜欢一支乐队，你不想站在人群的边缘一样。
You want to be right in the center. So people seek out the center of the crowd and feel safest, even when it's, you're going to be right. It's dangerous. So it is true that this psychological sense of safety with others who are in group can lead you into danger. And similarly, we found that when you feel that others are in group, you might be more willing, for instance, to share drinks, food, makeup, whatever with them. And again, that can lead the spread of the disease. So there are some paradoxical effects where what is a psychological good can be a public health problem. And I think it's important for people to be aware of those types of issues. So I want to change gears for a minute and go back to something
你想要直奔中心。因此，人们寻找人群的中心并感到最安全，即使在——你是对的。这是危险的。因此，这种与内群体其他成员在一起的心理安全感确实会把你带入危险之中。同样，我们发现，当你觉得其他人是内群体时，你可能更愿意，例如，与他们分享饮料、食物、化妆品等。同样，这会导致疾病的传播。因此，存在一些悖论效应，即心理上的好事可能会成为公共卫生问题。我认为人们意识到这些类型的问题很重要。所以我想换个话题，回到我
I mentioned in the introduction, which is the fact that you've studied two of the most famous experiments in all of psychology, both of which were on obedience and authority. Stanley Milgram shock experiments in the 1960s and the Stanford Prison Experiment in the early 1970s. Our listeners who remember these from their Psychology 101 classes probably learned from these that people are surprisingly willing to obey authority figures blindly with no questioning, even to the point of hurting or killing strangers. But in recent years, you and other researchers have argued that these experiments have been misunderstood and misinterpreted.
在引言中提到的一点，那就是你研究了心理学史上两个最著名的实验，这两个实验都是关于服从和权威的。20世纪60年代斯坦利·米尔格拉姆的电击实验以及20世纪70年代初的斯坦福监狱实验。我们的听众如果在心理学101课程中记得这些，可能会从这些实验中了解到，人们出奇地愿意盲目服从权威人物，毫无疑问，甚至到了伤害或杀死陌生人的地步。但在近年来，你和其他研究人员认为这些实验被误解和曲解了。
Can you talk about that? What lessons did you take from these classic studies about obedience and authority? So let me come at this a couple of ways. First of all, let me step back to talk more generally about leadership, because I think leadership for us is critical to what happens in these two studies. Now, from our perspective, because we look at the way in which people behave in groups and how we show how in crowds people seek to behave in groups, people seek to behave in ways that express their group identity, then the implication is that anyone
你能谈谈这个吗？你从这些关于服从和权威的经典研究中汲取了什么教训？所以我可以从几个方面来谈这个问题。首先，让我退一步，更广泛地谈谈领导力，因为我认为领导力对我们理解这两个实验中发生的事情至关重要。现在，从我们的角度来看，因为我们关注人们在群体中的行为方式，以及我们如何展示在人群中人们如何试图在群体中行为，人们试图以表达其群体认同的方式行事，那么这意味着任何
who is in a position to tell you what it means to be a member of this group. What does it mean to be American in this context? What does it mean to be a Catholic in this context or whatever? Is in a position to influence our behavior. In other words, leadership should be seen as a group process where the leader influenced us by telling us who we are. And when you begin to think about it, I mean, leadership is always a group process. Somebody who people who belong to one group think is the most wonderful leader in the world, people who don't belong to that group think is the most awful thing who has ever existed. That was true in the UK with Margaret Thatcher. Some people adored her, thought she was charismatic and wonderful, and other people just
处于能够告诉你成为该群体成员意味着什么位置的人。在这个背景下，作为一个美国人意味着什么？在这个背景下，作为一个天主教徒意味着什么，等等。他们就有能力影响我们的行为。换句话说，领导力应该被视为一个群体过程，领导者通过告诉我们我们是谁来影响我们。当你开始思考时，我的意思是，领导力永远是一个群体过程。属于某个群体的人认为世界上最美妙的领导者，不属于该群体的人却认为那是曾存在过的最糟糕的人。在英国的玛格丽特·撒切尔身上就是如此。有些人崇拜她，认为她极具魅力且非常棒，而另一些人则认为
couldn't see it. It's happening, of course, today with the United States, with Donald Trump, with some people thinking, you know, he is fantastic and can do no wrong, and others thinking he can do no right. So very much leadership is a group process. It's about defining who we are and what we should do. So with that in mind, let me go back to these classic studies. And as you say, these studies are incredibly well known. If you ask people, if you ask students, for instance, the best known studies in all of psychology, not social psychology, all of psychology, they will say number one milgram, number two, Zimbardo. When I teach about these things, I have taught teachers, I've taught police officers, I've taught army personnel, all sorts of groups, about 60 or 70 percent of them know of these studies. They might not know the name, but when you say, do you remember these studies where they gave you electric shots if you made errors?
看不见。当然，现在美国也正在发生这种情况，比如唐纳德·特朗普，有些人觉得，你知道的，他太棒了，永远不会犯错，而另一些人则觉得他什么都做不对。所以，领导力在很大程度上是一个群体过程。它关乎定义我们是谁以及我们应该做什么。因此，带着这个想法，让我回到这些经典研究上来。正如你所说，这些研究极其知名。如果你去问人们，比如问学生，心理学中知名度最高的研究是什么，不是社会心理学，而是整个心理学，他们会说第一名是米尔格拉姆，第二名是津巴多。当我讲授这些内容时，我教过老师、警察、军队人员以及各种群体，大约百分之六十或七十的人都知道这些研究。他们可能不知道名字，但当你对他们说，你还记得那些如果你犯了错就会给你电击的研究吗？
And I'll say, oh yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, I know about those. So they're very, very well known. And the third thing to be said about them is the mythology has, in a sense, preceded the fact in terms of what actually happened. So let me start with Milgram. And what we learn from Milgram is somebody's brought into the laboratory for what they think is a memory experiment. They're told this is really important study and we're trying to find out how punishment impacts learning. These are the first studies and this will help us understand how to get people to learn. So what you've got to do is to teach somebody this word list and then test them.
他们会说，哦，对，对，对，我知道那些。所以它们非常非常知名。关于这些研究，第二点要说的是，在实际发生了什么方面，神话在某种程度上先于事实。所以，让我从米尔格拉姆开始讲起。我们从米尔格拉姆那里学到的是，有人被带进实验室，参加他们认为是一项记忆实验的研究。他们被告知这是一项非常重要的研究，我们正试图找出惩罚如何影响学习。这是最早的研究，这将帮助我们了解如何让人们去学习。所以你要做的是教给某人这个单词表，然后对他们进行测试。
And each time they make an error, give them an electric shock. And each time the electric shock will increase by 15, 30, 40, 60. How far will they go? That was the question Milgram started with. He didn't know what the answer was. He didn't think people would go very far. In fact, he asked people beforehand, and whether they were ordinary people students or whether they were experts, psychiatrists, they said that nobody will go all the way.
每次他们犯错，就给他们一次电击。而且每次电击会增加15、30、40、60伏。他们会走多远？这就是米尔格拉姆开始时提出的问题。他当时并不知道答案是什么。他原以为人们不会走得太远。事实上，他事先询问过人们，无论是普通人、学生还是专家、精神病学家，他们都说没有人会一路坚持到底。
Nobody will go to 450 volts. Nobody will murder someone because they make... errors on a learning experiment. Of course, the shocks weren't real, nobody was being hurt, but they believed they were. And what he found in the so-called classic baseline study, it's actually called the revised baseline study, was that 65% of people went all the way to 450 volts. Two-thirds of people would murder someone for making an error on a learning experiment. And this was in 1961, the same time that the architect of the Holocaust, the man who deported people to the death camps, Adolf Eichmann, precisely the same time he was in trial in Jerusalem. So the two events came together to shape our understanding.
没有人会把电压加到450伏。没有人会因为在学习实验中犯了……错误而去谋杀别人。当然，电击不是真的，没有人受伤，但他们相信这是真的。他在所谓的经典基线研究中发现——实际上它被称为修订版基线研究——百分之六十五的人一直坚持到了450伏。三分之二的人会为了学习实验中的一个小错误而谋杀别人。这是在1961年，也就是大屠杀的策划者、负责将人们驱逐到死亡集中营的阿道夫·艾希曼在耶路撒冷受审的同一年。这两个事件交织在一起，塑造了我们的理解。
Our understanding up until then had been, what's wrong with them? What's wrong with these people who can kill in Nazi Germany? surely they must be different from you or me. And what Milgram, to some extent, what happened with Eichmann and Hannah O'Rent's famous book on Eichmann seemed to show was actually we could do it. You or I could do it. So the question becomes, what would we do in those circumstances? And that's much more disturbing.
在那之前，我们的理解一直是：他们怎么了？纳粹德国那些能够杀人的人到底出了什么问题？他们肯定和你或我不同。而米尔格拉姆的研究，在某种程度上，加上艾希曼的经历以及汉娜·阿伦特关于艾希曼的名著，似乎表明其实我们也能做到。你或我都能做到。于是问题变成了：在那种情况下我们会怎么做？这就让人不安得多了。
It's much easier if you can put it onto someone else rather than look at yourself. So for me, Milgram studies are incredibly important. I might challenge some of the interpretations, but the way in which he got us to look at probably the most significant event, certainly of the 20th century, in a completely different way and change our psychological understanding of it, I think is incredibly important. So I am very well aware that we are standing on giant shoulders.
如果你能把责任推给别人，而不是审视自己，那就容易得多了。所以对我来说，米尔格拉姆的研究极其重要。我可能会质疑其中的某些解释，但他让我们用一种完全不同的方式去看待可能是有史以来（当然是20世纪）最重大的事件，并改变了我们对它的心理学理解，我认为这极其重要。因此，我非常清楚我们是站在巨人的肩膀上。
I'm not trying to debunk Milgram or attack Milgram. I'm saying what he did was incredibly important, but does his explanation stand up? Now, Milgram's explanation, he claims he takes from a Rents book on Eichmann and her concept of the banality of evil. And he says, look, people fall into an eugenic state, which means they just want to be a good follower. they want to carry out the experimenter's instructions, and they're so focused on that, those banal motives of wanting to be approved of by the experimenter by the authority figure.
我并不是想揭穿米尔格拉姆的底牌，也不是在攻击米尔格拉姆。我是说他的工作极其重要，但他的解释站得住脚吗？现在来看米尔格拉姆的解释，他声称自己借鉴了阿伦特关于艾希曼的书以及她关于平庸之恶的概念。他说，看哪，人们陷入了一种代理状态，这意味着他们只想做一个好的追随者。他们只想执行实验者的指令，他们太专注于此，专注于那些想从实验者、权威人物那里获得认可的平庸动机。
They're so focused on that, they don't notice what they're doing. They don't notice that they're imposing such harm. Now, even Milgram's fans, and actually I'm one of his fans, but even those who are uncritical say, look, really this explanation doesn't stand up. it doesn't stand up for all sorts of reasons.
他们太专注于此，以至于没有注意到自己在做什么。他们没有注意到自己正在造成如此巨大的伤害。现在，即使是米尔格拉姆的崇拜者——事实上我也是他的崇拜者之一——甚至那些不加批判的人也说，这种解释确实站不住脚。由于各种原因，它根本站不住脚。
One is there is a film. One of the reasons why Milgram studies are so famous is because he filmed them. And in the film, you can see this figure struggling as he goes through the experiment. One thing, should I continue asking questions, being torn? This isn't somebody who's unaware of what's happening. This is somebody who's torn apart by what he's being asked to do, which on the one hand, he knows. knows is wrong, somebody's being harmed, but on the other hand, he thinks he's doing something
首先，有一部电影。米尔格拉姆的研究之所以如此著名，原因之一是他把实验过程拍成了电影。在电影中，你可以看到这个人经历实验时的挣扎。比如：我应该继续提问吗？内心饱受煎熬。这并不是一个对发生的事情毫无察觉的人，而是一个被他被要求做的事情折磨得痛苦不堪的人。一方面，他知道这是不对的，有人正在受到伤害；但另一方面，他认为自己正在做一些
good and scientifically important. So it doesn't stand up for that reason. It doesn't stand up because despite the fact that we remember the, you know, let a Milgram study as people go all the way, remember two thirds go all the way in the one study, which means that a third don't. And if everybody fell into an agentic state, how do you explain that? Secondly, Milgram did 30 variants of his studies. He tried to tease apart when would it happen. And across all of these studies, actually, people disobey 58% of the time. So these are not studies of obedience. They're studies of obedience and disobedience. And when you come to ask, well, why did behaviour vary, what begins to become apparent, and we've shown this, is that the conditions where people are less likely to obey
有益且具有重大科学意义的事情。所以从这个理由来看，它站不住脚。它站不住脚的另一个原因是，尽管我们记得……你知道的，记住米尔格拉姆的研究中人们会一路坚持到底，但请记住，在一项研究中是三分之二的人坚持到底，这意味着还有三分之一的人没有。如果所有人都陷入了代理状态，你如何解释这一点？其次，米尔格拉姆对他的研究进行了30种变体测试。他试图探究这种情况会在什么时候发生。而在所有这些研究中，实际上人们有百分之五十八的时间选择了违抗。所以这些并不是关于服从的研究。它们是关于服从与违抗的研究。当你问及为什么行为会有所不同时，开始变得明显的是——我们也已经证明了这一点——人们不太可能服从的条件
tend to be ones where the authority figure is less legitimate and you're less likely to identify with him. It always was a man. So in one variant of the study, or in most variants of the study, they're done in Yale. So you have a prestigious Yale academic. In one, it's done in downtown Bridgett, in the... sort of dusty commercial building. And so it's less legitimate. You're less likely to identify.
往往是权威人物不那么合法，而且你不太可能认同他的时候。实验者一直是个男性。因此，在研究的一种变体中，或者在大多数研究变体中，它们是在耶鲁大学进行的。所以你有一个享有声望的耶鲁学者。而在其中一项变体中，它是在布里奇波特市中心的一个……有些灰尘的商业大楼里进行的。因此它的合法性较低。你更不太可能去认同。
And so we argue that what's going on here is not that you don't know what's happening. It's that you're actually placed between two different moralities. You have an experiment who tells you, look, what you're doing is good. what you're doing is progressive. What you're doing helps society by helpers, helping us understand learning. And it's very important that you continue with this experiment. So on the one hand,
所以我们认为，这里发生的事情并不是你不知道正在发生什么。而是你实际上处于两种不同的道德观念之间。你有一个实验者告诉你，看，你所做的是好的。你所做的是进步的。你所做的事情通过帮助我们理解学习来帮助社会。而且你继续这个实验非常重要。所以一方面，
you genuinely think you're doing something good and worthwhile. But on the other hand, a different voice, the voice of the learner, is telling you, you're hurting me, you're harming me. Have you got no right to do this to me? So you're placed between these two voices, which one do you listen to? And the more that the experimenter can persuade you to identify with him and identify with a scientific enterprise, then the more that you will be a willing follower,
你真心觉得自己在做好事，在做有价值的事。但另一方面，另一个声音，也就是学习者的声音，在告诉你，你在伤害我，你在毁了我。你有什么权力对我这么做？所以你夹在这两个声音之间，你听从哪一个？实验者越能说服你认同他并认同科学事业，你就会越情愿做一个顺从的追随者，
and the more that you identify with the victim, the less you will follow the experimenter. So it's an act of leadership, of leadership of trying to get you to identify with the experimenter and with the scientific cause, and that the more, as I say, the experimenter is successful in that, the more harm will be done. And so the point is this. People don't commit harm because they're unaware of it.
而你对受害者的认同感越强，你听从实验者的可能性就越小。所以这是一种领导力的行为，一种试图让你认同实验者和科学事业的领导力行为，而且正如我所说，实验者在这方面越成功，造成的伤害就会越大。所以关键在于：人们作恶并不是因为他们没有意识到这一点。
They're perfectly aware of it. Eichmann was perfectly aware of the fact he was deporting people to Auschwitz to die. No, it's because you are persuaded that what you are doing serves the greater good. And often when you look at history at the most obscene of regimes, the most extreme of actions, they argue that they are serving a greater good. I mean, and the Nazis did that as well. The Nazis attempted to argue that they were pursuing a particular form of morality, that Germany was seen as
他们对此心知肚明。艾希曼完全清楚他正在把人们驱逐到奥斯威辛去送死。不，这是因为你被说服了，认为你所做的事情是为了更大的善。通常当你回看历史上最令人发指的政权、最极端的行为时，他们都会辩称自己是在为更大的善服务。我的意思是，纳粹也这样做过。纳粹曾试图辩称他们是在追求某种特定形式的道德，即德国被视为
a good, that Germany was seen as embodying virtues, that Germany was about cleanliness, and that they were eliminating what they constituted as threats to that. So when they talk about racial hygiene, they meant it literally. Now, these are obscene ideas, but you can only challenge them if you understand how they work. And time and again, you get similar arguments, and we see arguments today,
一种善，德国被视为美德的化身，德国关乎纯洁，而他们正在清除他们所认为的对这一切的威胁。因此，当他们谈论种族卫生时，他们是字面意思上的意思。现在，这些都是荒谬的想法，但你只有理解它们是如何运作的，才能挑战它们。而且一次又一次，你会听到类似的论点，我们今天也能看到这样的论点，
which justify doing harm on the basis of the greater good and identifying with a greater good cause. So as I say, we hope that our work and our reinterpretation of that incredibly powerful phenomenon that Milgram displayed to us will make us more aware of when we too are following those dangerous steps to doing harm in the name of the greater good. Let me close by asking you about the coronation that you just attended since you spent so many hours out there in the rain. Did you see anything that you didn't expect?
它们以更大的善和认同更大的善为由，为主张造成伤害的行为进行辩解。所以正如我所说，我们希望我们的工作以及对米尔格拉姆向我们展示的那个极其强大的现象的重新诠释，能让我们更加警惕：什么时候我们也会以更大的善的名义，步入那些导致伤害的危险步伐。最后，我想问你关于你刚刚参加的加冕典礼的问题，既然你在雨中呆了那么长时间。你有没有看到什么意料之外的事情？
I mean, clearly you were there studying as well as participating. What was that like for you and what were your observations? Well, you know, I love crowds. And one of the things I always say about being an academic is, you know, the great thing about an academic life is people pay you to study about things that you find in. So I find crowds fascinating. And so I can go to a football crowd. I can go to a political rally. I can go to the coronation and I can say I'm collecting data. And that's a huge privilege and it's a huge pleasure. See, I started my study of crowds. In 1980, I was doing my PhD, doing my doctorate, sitting in a lab, doing social influence experiments when the first of the
我的意思是，显然你在那里既是去研究也是去参与。那对你来说是什么体验？你有什么观察？嗯，你知道的，我喜欢人群。关于成为一名学者，我总是说的一点是，学术生活最棒的地方在于人们付钱让你去研究你觉得有趣的事情。所以我发现人群非常迷人。因此我可以去一个足球观众群。我可以去一个政治集会。我可以去参加加冕典礼，然后可以说我在收集数据。这是一种巨大的特权，也是一种巨大的快乐。你看，我开始研究人群是在1980年。当时我正在攻读博士学位，坐在实验室里做社会影响实验，这时1980年代的英国城市骚乱爆发了，
British urban riots of the 1980s happened, St. Paul's riots. And I found it fascinating. And It so challenged these notions of mad mob, which were in all the newspapers the next day, that it set me on a course of study and I'm still going there. But for most of my life, I've been interested in protest crowds and how crowds challenge the status quo. But what we underestimate, I think, is the role of, if you like, establishment crowds, crowds which affirm the status quo, crowds which help create the identities by which we live our lives. So one thing that fascinated me, I studied the crowds around the Queen's mourning, the Queen's death, then the coronation. And they, I think, are very important in helping create
圣保罗骚乱。我发现这太迷人了。它极大地挑战了第二天所有报纸上都在鼓吹的“疯狂暴徒”观念，以至于它让我踏上了一条研究之路，并且我一直坚持到现在。但在我生命的大部分时间里，我一直对抗议人群以及人群如何挑战现状感兴趣。但我认为，我们低估了那种所谓的建制人群的作用，即那些肯定现状的人群，那些帮助塑造我们生活认同感的人群。所以有一件事让我着迷，我研究了女王哀悼期间、女王去世时以及随后的加冕典礼周围的人群。我认为它们对于创造
a sense of Britishness and to redefine that sense of Britishness. So although not everybody who went to the morning, and although not everybody who went to the coronation was a royalist, many people were there because it was an interesting thing. It was a historic event. They went to be with others. They went because they were tourists. It was seen as a huge crowd of people who supported the monarchy and therefore affirmed a particular version of Britishness. At a time where Britain is not doing desperately well in the world post-Brexit, it gave a sense of pride, look at the way we choreographed these things, look at the ways in which we're linked to history, look at the ways in which other countries look at us, and in that sense,
一种英国人身份认同感以及重新定义这种英国人身份认同感非常重要。因此，尽管并非所有去参加哀悼的人、并非所有去参加加冕典礼的人都是保皇派，但许多人去那里是因为这是一件有趣的事情。这是一场历史事件。他们去是为了和别人在一起。他们去是因为他们是游客。它被视为一大群支持君主制的人，因此肯定了某种特定版本的英国身份。在一个英国在脱欧后的世界里过得并不是特别好的时期，它带来了一种自豪感：看看我们是如何策划这些事情的，看看我们与历史的联系方式，看看其他国家是如何看待我们的，从这个意义上说，
it increased the sense of national identification, the sense of national pride. So I am fascinated, and we've collected the data. We haven't fully analysed it yet, because it only happened a few days ago in the ways in which crowds not only act on the basis of pre-existing identities, but the way in which crowds form the everyday identities by which we live. You see, the notion of crowds by and large has been they are an eruption of something primitive into contemporary life. They are like Victorian freak shows. They're fascinating, but they're not really relevant to the real stuff of psychology and
它增强了国民认同感和民族自豪感。所以我很着迷，而且我们已经收集了数据。我们还没有完全分析它，因为它在几天前才刚刚发生。我们关注人群不仅根据预先存在的身份行事的方式，还关注人群塑造我们赖以生存的日常身份的方式。你看，人们对人群的普遍看法是，它们是某种原始事物在当代生活中的爆发。它们就像维多利亚时代的畸形秀。它们很迷人，但与心理学的真正核心内容并没有太大关系，
society. For me, crowds both theoretically, but also practically, tell you about those basic processes which define who we are and how we relate to others and what we should do and how we feel. And I think in studying coronation crowds and mourning crowds and the ways in which these crowds help consolidate a particular understanding of our national identities, that contributes their understanding that crowd psychology should be very much at the center of psychology and the center of this understanding of society. Well, I think you've just made a very compelling case, and I want to thank you for joining me today. Dr. Reischer, it's been really interesting. It's been great to talk to you. Thank you.
社会也是如此。对伞兵、人群来说，无论是从理论上还是从实践上，它们都向你展示了那些定义了我们是谁、我们如何与他人建立联系、我们应该做什么以及我们如何感受的基本过程。我认为，通过研究加冕典礼人群、哀悼人群，以及这些人群如何帮助巩固对我们国家认同感的某种特定理解，这有助于深化这样一种认知：人群心理学应该非常坚定地处于心理学中心，并成为理解社会的中心。嗯，我想你刚刚做了一个非常令人信服的陈述，我要感谢你今天加入我们。瑞彻博士，这真的很有趣。与你交谈太棒了。谢谢你。
You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at www. www. speakingof psychology.org or on Apple, Stitcher, YouTube, or wherever you get your podcasts. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org. Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Winerman. Our sound editor is Chris Condyenne. Thank you for listening. For the American Psychological Association, I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
您可以在我们的网站 www. speakingof psychology.org 上找到往期的《心理学之声》节目，也可以在 Apple、Stitcher、YouTube 或您获取播客的任何地方收听。如果您对未来的播客有任何意见或想法，可以给我们发电子邮件，邮箱是 speaking of psychology at APA.org。《心理学之声》由李·威纳曼 (Lee Winerman) 制作。我们的音频编辑是克里斯·康迪安 (Chris Condyenne)。感谢您的收听。我是美国心理学协会的金·米尔斯 (Kim Mills)。本期节目暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可留下评论。